top of the malaskey corporate center
that's one of the buildings there off
the spaghetti bowl 95 east of the i-15
beautiful look over at the mid-strip and
of course the strat here it is a clear
sky we're keeping an eye on the
temperatures in your neighborhoods
officially 86 make that 84 degrees we've
dropped a couple degrees from an hour
ago our humidity is at 21 percent so the
headlines we're talking about the
excessive heat warning continuing with
record or near record temps at least
today and tomorrow before the wind comes
in on sunday that's where there's a fire
weather watch we're going to be over 90
by 8 over 100 at noon going for 105 by 3
this afternoon and an afternoon high of
109 now those neighborhood temperatures
we are dropping back to the 70s before
the sun comes up and really turns things
back around warm spot we've got a bunch
of 85 sunrise mountains seven hills and
anthem along the strip and in downtown
aliante the cool spot at 77.
dropping substantially
98 degrees an hour ago death valley
you're at 93 right now up in white pine
county always cooler ealey at 50
caliente you're at 80 59 in southwestern
utah there in cedar city again 109 the
forecast high more than 10 degrees above
normal if we get that far that's going
to set a new record high for today's
date current temperature 10 degrees
above normal for the low so far this
morning high pressure going to last at
least another day or two before the wind
comes blowing it right out of here there
are severe thunderstorms going on right
now for parts of oklahoma arkansas
scattered showers from minnesota through
iowa and missouri and
typical up in the pacific northwest some
light showers all the way towards into
montana but let's get your eight day
forecast going here 109 today again that
will set a new record these red numbers
are the current records for the next few
days 109 is the record high for tomorrow
we're going to stop at about 108 so it's
going to be close overnight lows though
in the mid 80s that's pretty warm then
the wind starts whipping gusts up to 40
miles an hour that's what that fire
weather watch is all about and then the
high temperature will back down a couple
degrees maybe the 90s for monday and
tuesday but then once the wind dies down
the heat comes back